bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfy.com to learn
more
all right let's get into this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got joshua
here with me in person in miami if
you're not miami
where are you really you're doing this
man thank you for having me he came
in with the swag on too with the nice
white sweatshirt it's way too hot for
miami but i should still do shameless
promotion
even if i'm hot for it it's all right i
wear a sweatshirt in here it's a little
chilly so it's fine
um let's just get started uh
how do you like miati let's start there
i love it it's like the land of the free
and i'm not just saying that
everyone here is um i was at a coffee
shop and uh the barista was like what do
you do and i was like i work in tech and
she's like oh you work in tech that's
great
but in san francisco you get a very
different attitude to that
what is the attitude in san francisco
just like dirty looks wear a mask
that sort of thing yeah i i laughed and
uh
when i saw i think was jason calcanis
tweeted the other day and he said uh
he got yelled in san francisco for not
wearing a mask and in austin texas he
got yelled at for wearing a mask
and i was like i don't know you know
like if that's a good thing or a bad
thing but it very much highlights the
difference of the attitudes uh
in terms of like individual sovereignty
and their relationship with government
rules in those two places right yeah
miami's neutral no one gets upset with
you either way
i tend to think that's the right way to
think about it um all right do not pay
it's one of these companies where i feel
like
everyone loves what you guys are doing
uh let's just start with like your
background where did you grow up
uh you've got an incredible story and
your family's been involved in a whole
bunch of crazy stuff
uh before you start the company so maybe
just walk us through like your life
before you start the company
so um i was a high school student in
england and
um it was my dream to come to silicon
valley i taught myself to code using
like stanford's youtube videos and i
thought if i can get there to this place
it's a dream come true
and so i got into stanford and moved
there six years ago now
and when i went there it lived up to my
expectations
i was in the center of silicon valley
and it really changed my life and
allowed me to start do not pay
why do you say that it lived up to your
expectations like what were the
expectations and then what were the
parts of stanford and silicon valley
that you were like wow this is like the
place i want to be
i think um america is the land of
opportunity the most successful company
in the uk is maybe deliveroo
um but the most successful company in
the us is stripe i'd much rather be
closer to stripe than deliver
and lots of the vcs and my friends
starting companies have the same
attitude
yeah and so when you get there did you
know you want to start a company was it
more so just i want to be in the
technology industry like what was your
thought process going into stanford and
in the first you know a couple months or
years that you're there
i always knew i wanted to tinker with
projects as an engineer but
i fell into my company do not pay by
accident by getting all these parking
tickets
we'll get to the parking tickets in a
second you told me a story before it's
absurd
uh growing up though your dad uh went to
russia and had this ridiculous
uh kind of experience where basically
he's an american in a foreign country uh
really
um understood how to invest capital in a
very kind of uh
compound that capital a very aggressive
uh pace but
it's russia and there's all kinds of
crazy stuff that goes on there from a
political standpoint from a safety
standpoint
and his experience ends up being written
into a book red notice
uh bill browder for those that don't
know and uh
what is your kind of like understanding
of this as you're growing up do you know
what's going on do are you kind of
sheltered from a lot of this
like just what was it as a young kid
first
um it was very scary um i think the
scariest aspect was when my father
devoted everything to fight the russians
and it's one thing to go after
like maybe like government bureaucrats
or have legal problems but it's another
thing to go after the mafia and so lots
of scary things happened he was deported
his lawyer was murdered and it really
taught me to be fearless in life
it puts everything in perspective
when something minor happens i just
think it could be a lot worse
yeah and so when i read the book i
didn't know you i
obviously didn't know him uh the thing
that i took away from it was just like
you hear these stories of eastern europe
or russia or you know
wherever around the world you're like it
can't really be that bad
it was really that bad right when you
read the story it's insane
uh why do you think your dad actually
like drew the line in the sand and say
i'm gonna go devote my life essentially
to go and fight this and obviously the
manitsky act and a whole bunch of stuff
that has come out of it
um has been kind of the the fruits of
that labor but
what kind of drove that decision i think
for him when
um and i can't speak for him but when
his lawyer was murdered
um he he felt like he was a part of that
and so
he wants to get justice for the lawyer
the lawyer gave his life
for justice and so the least he could do
was give his life uh for
justice for the lawyer yeah and so for
you now that you're older and you kind
of look back to that time is there
anything that you kind of take away now
that maybe you didn't appreciate it at
the time or didn't really understand
that was happening
i think um just how unjust the world can
be
i think in silicon valley or even in the
uk people can tell themselves the world
is so great it's so great out there but
there are some really bad people and
some really bad things going on
yeah so that brings me to my favorite
question always uh it's cheating when i
talk to a technologist but
technology net positive or net negative
for the world
strong net positive i i feel like anyone
who says that is probably
in san francisco still which is ironic
that it's in that negativity yeah
i i i mean i i it's uh when i worked at
facebook people would always bring this
up right like facebook is like you know
ruining the world it's like well hold on
a second like
sure of course there's negative impacts
when you connect a bunch of humans but
it's more so you're probably just
allowing humans to be humans
uh but look at all of the positive
impact right people can stay in touch
with their families they can share
photos they can learn things they can
communicate like all this is a net
positive
and so the negative side effects of
technology seem to be very very
minuscule compared to the the positive
aspects
i think technology is um being used for
some very negative things but
in aggregate it's very positive and
that's what i see with do not pay we're
trying to bring the positive aspects of
technology to the legal system it's
already being used in the negative
aspects like algorithmic sentencing and
things we want to give that power to the
consumer
yeah and so when you think of like the
negative aspects is that mostly like big
technology companies
is it like nefarious or malicious actors
or do you think a lot of us just people
are trying to use technology and then
there's negative side effects that they
maybe didn't intend
or didn't realize when they started i
think um
it's a weapon and um the the weapons in
life immediately go to the rich
and powerful big corporations and then
over time trickle down
to consumers and so i think it's just
being used by the people that want to
use it negatively at the moment
yeah uh you start do not pay and it all
starts with parking tickets on
stanford's campus
from my understanding uh tell us that
story of why were you getting so many
parking tickets
well everyone drives on the other side
of the road here and i was a terrible
driver
and um i would not have time to scratch
a permit because i was going to class or
park perfectly in the bay and what i
learned is
in stanford but more so in san francisco
the government issues tickets
not necessarily to punish people i'm a
very unsympathetic and terrible driver
but sometimes to raise money um and
i couldn't afford to pay the tickets
they're like a hundred dollars
a piece um and so i had to become an
expert getting out of them
and there was this rumor among my
friends that i was the parking ticket
guy
and so all of a sudden they all started
asking me for my help as well
and i was spending maybe two hours a day
on microsoft word back then
copying and pasting documents for my
friends and i thought what am i doing
with my life like why isn't this
automated and more so
why do you have to pay a lawyer 50 of
the cost of the ticket
um if you don't have the time to
research for hours in the night like i
do
so i created the first version of do not
pay just
for fun really to impress my friends and
we went from one case on day one myself
um to about a dozen cases on day to all
my friends who i now no longer had to
waste time on microsoft word for
um to 30 000 cases on day three because
one of my friends um was a blogger at
the huffington post
and she wrote about it and it went
internationally viral because it turns
out everyone in the world hates parking
tickets
and so did it work on like every college
campus did it work
for any city or how did it work on day
one on day one it worked for all of the
uk
and stanford um so no it didn't
people were just submitting cases and uh
it wouldn't actually work for them
and so i thought i have to expand this
thing really quickly
like 30 000 people are showing up but i
can't help them exactly
they're going to turn their uh their
anger and madness on me rather than uh
rather than on the people giving the
parking ticket yeah and i had like 12
followers on twitter at the time i had
never
gone viral being contacted by anyone and
all of a sudden i was getting like 300
angry emails a day
saying like uh by the way can you help
me with my comcast dispute as well
really and so after the parking ticket
uh kind of
i don't know dispute right uh platform
or product what did you build next
i really used all these emails to go
after corporations so
i started with airlines and and then the
next big product after that was helping
people sue equifax
for the big data breach and so all
you're doing is you're basically
creating almost a form to some degree
right and it automates
hey enter in your information around you
specifically whether it's your name your
claim number whatever it is
uh and then you guys would do everything
from generate demand letters or kind of
dispute letters
all the way to actually file things for
folks uh
and so as you're doing this it seems
like you're almost like just listening
to customers they tell you hey i have a
problem you guys write some software
okay now we can solve that you have 200
of these yes
at what point are you like hey this
isn't like me impressing my friends
anymore like this is gonna be a company
like
when does that kind of hit you i think
about a year in
i um one of the vc partners on sandhill
road actually used do not pay
successfully and he convinced me to make
it into a company and so i did the
standard roadshow pitching
to lots of vc firms and i was lucky
andres and horowitz
believed in me and invested a million to
get it off the ground
okay and do they have to like convince
you like did you not want to start a
company and they had to like convince
you to do it or what is that first
conversation like
i will i believe companies are the way
that things get done in
in the world and so i knew i wanted to
start a company but at the same time i
didn't have any business model i was
just like i love
this product i hate the government i
want to build a product to fight the
government
i didn't know how i would charge people
or what would the business model be
yeah and so as you're starting to raise
the money
uh what are like the funny conversations
like right does every investor
immediately get in there
i guess this is amazing or are there
people who are just like dude what are
you talking about this is
crazy and you know i'm not funding a
parking ticket dispute company
yeah that was like 90 of the
conversations but
at that point i pre it was still parking
tickets but i had the vision of
expanding to other areas and i was lucky
they believed in that
yeah and so when you race capital what
do you do next do you go hire a bunch of
people do you just sit on the cash
what'd you guys do
um we rented uh the mark zucker
the house mark zuckerberg started
facebooking and was super lean
and just stayed there for months on end
creating more bots
so we did the airlines we did equifax
landlord tenant disputes
and over time we had enough bots that
eventually we could charge a
subscription
all right why mark zuckerberg's first
facebook house is there like some
element of
uh specifically seeking that house out
was it some kind of like
message to the world why that house it
was great marketing because um every
other day a bus of people would come
and we could just give them do not pay
app invites
what and the landlord was a relic of a
different era
and so he didn't really use zillow or
know how much the house was worth so we
actually got a great deal on that and we
didn't actually find it as mark
zuckerberg's house we just found it as a
cheap house and later
found out when we're signing the lease
that we got a good deal
really yes and so when people show up on
like tours or like how are they showing
up
yeah they show up on tours because
everyone comes from around the world to
see this house that we were just living
in it's really not a very nice house
yeah and so then you guys would have
like flyers or how would you like hand
out the invites
yeah so usually they wouldn't expect to
be let in um but we would say come on in
however you have to put your email down
to enter the house
ah that's smart yeah and then would you
guys like give like a tour inside the
house or just like let them one yeah
we'd have to waste some time with the
tour and
come up with some story
[Laughter]
right here let me tell you what mark did
in the living room exactly that's right
we were just trying to get emails for
our initial uses
what's the craziest story you think you
guys made up about the house i mean we
didn't make anything up but we're like
this is mark's bad
and it probably was mark's bed but still
all right so i've seen you describe do
not pay as a compound startup this whole
idea of it kind of continues to grow
accelerate build on top of itself
just where does that terminology come
from like how do you think about
a startup uh kind of going from idea to
a compound startup and what does that
take
being a compound startup kind of um goes
against all the typical
advice it's more popular now but when we
started it wasn't very popular the
typical advice is focus on one small
thing and grow from there
the problem with do not pay is that the
average driver unless you're a bad
driver like me only gets a parking
ticket once
once a year so they would forget about
the service
every time they use it and you'd have to
reacquire the customer and all this
stuff
so i knew for do not pay to be
successful would have to help a consumer
every month and luckily there are many
disputes that a consumer
has people are being ripped off left
right and center but
um one has to build that so i actually
spent
four years building out the
infrastructure to generate these letters
send it off to the right place before i
felt comfortable even charging people
yeah
and so when you think through kind of
the product today
uh is it just automated lawyers
essentially or like how do you describe
it to people
i like to think of it um as the general
counsel
for the consumer i don't tell consumers
that because no one knows what a general
counsel is but a robot lawyer general
counsel
and they're sitting on their shoulders
watching their back
so when comcast send a 1 000 debt
collection letter
they can come to do not pay and have
some recourse to fight back
so uh there's a lot of similarities
between your dad going and kind of
seeking justice right
and then you basically uh going up
against these corporations going up
against you know local governments who
you know are fundraising through parking
tickets etc uh you've been called the
robin hood of the internet which is just
one a
badass name to be called undeserved
maybe in 20 years but like is there an
element of
uh we're using technology to kind of
fight back against the system or is that
just kind of happenstance people like to
spin that story
no i really dislike authority and just
love to live free which is why i think
miami aligns with the do not pay values
the legal system is very protectionist
to be a lawyer you have to get the stamp
of approval
from a bar association and if you're
representing a consumer and you're not a
lawyer
you can even spend time in prison so
they're very protective because they
like to keep their 1
800 average fee for the top 50 law firms
yeah and so as you build this g is there
a way that you guys like measure
impact or dollars or like the severity
of the problem when you say hey we've
got 200 products today we're gonna add
the 201st one like how do you
evaluate what's the next thing you go do
by the end of this year we're looking to
save around 100 million in aggregate for
consumers
um a lot of our products save people
time
like cancelling subscriptions um as well
yeah
and so when you evaluate that new
product right let's say you have three
different options to choose from like
what's the framework you use to say like
we should launch this one before you
know the other two so we have three
rules for ourselves the first is it has
to be truly mass market
50 million americans plus um everyone
gets robocalls for example
and that precludes a lot of ideas like
startup tax credits that's not something
we would ever do
the second rule is it has to be fully
automated um
we've built tools to phone up the dmv
and do all the clicking so we
automated is a big scope for us but we
can't have an army of people typing out
these letters
and then the third is it has to be
related to consumer rights
yeah and so when you think about kind of
doing this i think a lot of people look
and say hey it's you know
joshua the do not pay team and the
consumer versus the man
right and it's very much uh kind of
taking back rights uh
using technology to uh to do this but
also
in many cases you're actually just
reducing friction you're reducing
barrier to
uh things that people have a right to so
for example the pandemic relief right
there was all kinds of programs created
there was all sorts of money
or services that were available to folks
one they may not know
or two it may just suck to go and apply
and so you guys it sounds like created a
whole bunch of products
that could help them do that talk a
little bit just about the pandemic and
those types of products
yeah so at the height of the pandemic we
were at about 20
unemployment and so all of the state
unemployment systems built
maybe during the 1960s completely
crashed and people were really
upset by that and so what do not pay did
is we found a workaround
it turns out that the u.s mail is the
api for the government
and although they had all these online
systems you could still send in the
paper form
so we built a bot to fill in the form
for unemployment benefits
in all 50 states and mailed it in
automatically with an api
so when you do that like i go online
right i basically type in my information
what happens from there until physical
piece of paper is mailed
um it will go through the questions and
explain the questions to you because
sometimes you don't even know you're
giving up rights by saying yes or no to
these
questions um and once it does that it
generates all the paperwork in under
30 seconds and mails off to the right
place got it and so basically
it almost like takes the answer from a
digital form it then like prints out a
piece of paper that has it and then you
just have a human who grabs a piece of
paper puts it into an envelope and mails
it or do you even outsource that
uh there are apis now to do that it's a
great time to be alive
yeah that's why right so basically you
don't even have to deal with the
physical mail you're literally just
hitting an api
and some other company or product is
taken care of actually printing this
piece of paper putting it in an envelope
and mailing it yeah we don't go outside
we're just coding
okay yeah you don't go outside at all
no but just metaphorically yeah well you
know you're if you're in miami
it's nice to go outside here um
when you think about how many people use
these services for the pandemic related
stuff
like how does that compare in popularity
to your other products that weren't
pandemic related
um at the time it was a few hundred
thousand now it's died down and
the as the world is opening up all the
typical bureaucracy is increasing again
so dmv bureaucracy
all of that yep uh you're pushing back
against government and institutional
type overreach
uh i'm assuming that they don't like you
i'm also assuming that they don't just
sit there and take it on the chin
yeah so what is the pushback from either
the uh
credit companies that you guys are kind
of pushing back against you know the
comcast of the world the local
government
uh any of the tax organizations et
cetera like just what what's kind of the
the pushback that you're receiving
it's an arms race so they try and block
do not pay from interacting with their
systems
completely so for example one product we
have is called the free trial credit
card it's a credit card you can sign up
for any free trial and it does it's not
linked to you
it's not even linked to your bank
account um and
netflix blocks our entire card network
from that so we have to switch it
and keep innovating to stop them
but we're more motivated than them so
i'm not too worried about it so you have
a product
where i can go i can use this it's
essentially a virtual card
right and then i can use that virtual
card to sign up for a free trial on
netflix
and if i forget to cancel it at the end
of the free trial i basically can't get
charged because it was never tied to
me in the risk okay and so
i'm assuming then at the end of the free
trial if they try to come back you guys
are canceling it being able to dispute
it or whatever right
yes and so they hate us yeah so you can
take a lot of risk mitigation
efforts uh when they figure out what
you're doing
they try to block you and then it's
literally a cat and mouse game of
can you figure another way in yeah and
we see this with the government too then
blocking our ips
so we've built this workaround where
when someone uses the do not pay app
the appeal is submitted from their ip
address on the phone so it's like very
decentralized
so they have to block all the ips um not
just one do not
pay ip so really what you're doing here
is you're essentially spending all day
long
figuring out not only one how to build
the automated systems and what products
to build
but then you're also building this like
uh almost anti-establishment
decentralized
technology stack that allows you guys to
continue to do this without having a
single point of failure
that that's exactly right i feel like i
have the best job in the world i didn't
know it's actually a real job to be
doing
[Laughter]
when i say that they must not like you
uh maybe i would underestimate it they
must really [ __ ] hate you
they really do yeah have they ever sent
you like cease and desist letters or
like what's like the worst thing that's
ever happened in terms of the pushback
we've certainly got lots of seasoned
disses letters
um we have a bot that lets us know
whenever someone signs up with the dot
gov
address and we get like three a day it's
very interesting everyone is signing up
from the government
across the us and they want to see how
it works or they want to use the service
to get out of a parking ticket or
something
both but they're trying to scope out and
what do you do if they sign up from a
gov address we leave them alone but we
watch them very carefully
[Laughter]
in some way now they're on your turf
right and so you you can
uh pay attention there is some positive
though when we launched in los angeles
npr
asked the head of the los angeles
parking ticket
bureau what he thought of do not pay and
he said i actually love it because
people write such gibberish
and their parking ticket appeals at
least when it comes from do not pay it's
standardized and that's better spin than
i even i could have come up with
yeah so really what they're saying is
like look if people are going to write
in then we'd rather
all be standardized and we know what it
says it has the information that we need
whatever
versus we have to read a bunch of
handwriting or whatever
yeah i think bureaucracy holds us all
back even the government
yeah so in some weird way even though
you're fighting them
by giving them a standardized letter or
information or whatever you can actually
make them better at their job and just
make it a more efficient process between
the dispute and the
government or the credit agency or
whatever yeah and we're very humble we
know that in new york city they make a
billion dollars a year from tickets
and so even if we're appealing a few
million dollars a year from new york
we're just a drop in the water so we're
actually saving them their biggest cost
base which is dealing with these appeals
yeah how bad is the government
bureaucracy
i it's it's really really bad even worse
than most people say
so for example um the federal government
only stopped using floppy disks entirely
in 2016.
floppy disks so and i'm assuming
that the switching cost for them to go
from floppy disk
to whatever technology they're using now
was not minuscule right like you see
these bills you see the budgets that
they have first like stupid stuff
yeah uh i think in one of the pandemic
uh relief bills
there was 25 million dollars in the bill
for cleaning supplies of the capitol
building
which by the way i don't know how big it
is i don't know how much the cleaning
supply should cost
but that just seems like 25 million
dollars is not one gonna last forever
right so like what is that for a year or
two of cleaning supplies and that just
seems like a lot
yeah um there's a really big scandal the
tsa was trying to make an
app that said should passengers go left
or right just randomly whether they
should go left or right it costs 1.4
million dollars
to just point an arrow in either
direction in a random format
and why did it cost so much they have
these contractors that
um take advantage of the situation and
are so entrenched with lobbyists and
things like that
and procurement processes that they get
the contract
is that a do not pay a potential product
in the future is the tsas left or right
app that you could just go and help them
out and buy some goodwill with them
it seems like uh they wouldn't like us
very much
are they scared that you may you may
start confusing people on purpose
to cause mass chaos at the tsa line yeah
all the amex colors can go right yeah
i love it uh when you think about the
company over the next like three
five ten years what does this become is
it just literally almost an army of like
robot lawyers and you just continue to
knock out product after product feature
uh and eventually you can kind of eat
into the everyday life right in terms of
just every single thing you interface
uh do not pay as a solution if you have
a problem or is there some other vision
that's exactly right but with the caveat
that dude you shouldn't even have to
know what do not pay is it should just
be um hey we've got you 500
in your bank account today so right now
people come to do not pay with a problem
um we want to make it so that do not pay
just comes with a solution that you
didn't even know about
and is this a purely subscription play
where you just are going to continue to
say hey pay us
one you know price point and then you're
going to get all of these like army of
robots
that are on your side forever just
constantly working for you
yeah i think it's best that we work for
our customers yeah
uh are there corporations or any types
of
you know products or things that you can
do with non-like retail or consumer
type customers or is it just continue to
serve the individual people
and everything else is a distraction i
think as long as it helps 50 million
people it doesn't matter who they are so
we've got small business products
finance products so we're looking to be
more sophisticated but it has to impact
everyone
yeah what is like a small business
product example
responding to dmca take down requests a
lot of websites get harassed
with these requests and do not pay can
just deal with them for you
what about patents anything in the
patent space you guys have looked at
that seems like the uh the patent trolls
are
having a field day these days i i
it's not something we can do you
probably have to go into court um
and also patents are being unwinded in
the u.s as we speak
yes is it the vaccines they're saying
that they're going to take away all the
patents or like to kind of like de-teeth
them i guess so that now people can
as a first step do we think that's a
good idea i think
um whenever you have inconsistency where
some rules are being applied differently
i've seen firsthand how that can go
snowball in the wrong direction so i
think that maybe the mission could be
good but
treating things inconsistently is never
a good idea in the legal system
yeah it feels like we got a crash course
in that over the last 12 months of local
state and federal governments
picking and choosing when to implement
certain rules and actually enforce them
or not
and the other part i think that we
learned is like there's a very big
difference between like law on the books
or rules in the book and then actually
enforcing them
and it feels like what you guys really
do is you essentially are looking at
what are the actual rules on the book
versus how are they being enforced and
there's some exploitation that you can
do there
in the name of the consumer to basically
fight back
right that's right yeah and how much of
the products you guys build is pure
technicality based like
hey we just know that if you do you know
send a letter
ask for this and yeah and you know i
don't know pay 20 bucks then you get out
of the parking ticket that was 300
versus it's more so um you know actually
the merit of the case
right where it's like the individual
details really matter we are
strongly focused on the law so there
have been companies in the past they
call them loophole companies where they
automate
credit card policies for example the
problem is that
the big companies only offer these
loopholes because they think no one will
use them
all of a sudden ai comes along and
automates the
price protection on your credit card and
the credit card company says
we're losing too much money we're going
to stop this overnight and so do not
pays entirely u.s
laws admittedly there are some areas
where
if you're sending this long note to
united's legal department
they're probably so scared that they
rule in your favor but at least it's
based in law rather than
um just some loophole yeah and so really
it's just a sustainability play right
it allows you to build products that
aren't going to disappear overnight
yes got it uh global launch uh or global
markets
i want to ask for people for questions
that seems to be like one of the big
areas that and android so i don't know
just all ios and desktop right now or
what's the platforms
everyone always says complains about
android but do not pay.com works
perfectly on all devices
and so do you have a ios app as well or
we do
okay do you have an android app no no
but the website works so just like the
mobile web
yes and it's really good all right so
android opinion
contains the mobile web and it should be
okay and you can add it to your home
screen as well oh so it's basically like
an app it's just like a
diy app right like just do it yourself
put on your own
homepage my thesis is i want to rely on
as few gatekeepers as possible
i accidentally relied on apple in the
past and i've had my issues with them
i'm not looking to expand to more
gatekeepers
what were the issues and why do you say
accidentally uh
relied on them well as a naive like
stanford former stanford student i
thought an app is great
but then i launched on the app store and
um it was good for a few years and one
day apple said
we want 30 and also you have too many
your app is too app store like um and so
you have 30 days
and so on election night they actually
removed us and only when there was
public uproar
and we changed their bet did they change
their mind and they wanted 30
of the subscription yes but there was a
point in time where they didn't take 30
percent
that's right okay they just change their
policies every day it's worse than the
government at least the government is
transparent and
um there are different judges but if
there's one corporation
they act in their own interests uh is it
monopoly
a hundred percent i'm thinking epic
games that's my one regret about leaving
the bay area i'd probably go to one
take a day off and go to the trial with
tim sweeney
do you think they're gonna win i i think
that um
50 50. the law is not so strong it
should be made stronger but it's so
egregious some of these emails what
apple are doing like
we will crush the competition in emails
that
um something's going to happen it is
pretty crazy
i haven't had a ton of attention but the
things that i've read i think on both
sides frankly right
it's like whoa this is way worse than we
thought both in terms of
uh the egregious and kind of the
overreach of the app store and the fees
and all the stuff
yeah uh but then also like what some of
the companies are doing
right where they explicitly know that
it's against the app store rules but
they're trying to do it to intentionally
kind of elicit the response and all of
that
uh but the other thing that i think was
the most surprising out of everything i
read was
there's this uh belief that hey we
always charge the same thing to every
app and then you find out like well
actually that's not true because there
are some applications that are allowed
to whether it's trials percentages
use their own payment processors within
their applications
and i think that like my takeaway from
all of it is like hey we all kind of
knew you were doing this so just don't
say that you're not doing it right like
if you just said hey look by the way
yeah
if you're [ __ ] amazon like you get to
use your payment processor inside the
app
if you're not amazon you don't get to do
that people won't like it but they're
just like okay like i'm not amazon right
instead when you're like oh everyone has
to play by the same rules and then it
comes out that you're not doing that
that's what it seems like it's almost
like you're uh
somebody once told me uh the crime's not
the worst part is the cover-up
like that feels like in this case that's
true yeah and in the amazon example they
they covered it up by saying oh no they
didn't get a special
deal that was part of the premium video
subscription program which they invented
just to cover up
this is a real real story uh
what about global markets uh you're in
the us in the uk
what other markets are you in and are
there certain markets that you're
thinking about going to that you're not
in today
i think do not pay will work anywhere
that has a rule of law so
canada south africa europe with that
said though the euro the u.s is stuck in
the 1980s so
we have too much work here before we
expand more why do you say it's stuck in
the 1980s
um several courts still require you to
fax documents
we have a list of 40 different products
coming up this year just in the us
so our work has cut out for us do can i
make a product suggestion which means
that it'll probably be stupid but you'll
uh you know we'll do
that next week okay so uh i got married
last year yeah and my wife went to
change her name
and there i think there are companies
where you can like mail your documents
in right and try to change all this
uh it's a nightmare but the thing that
blew my mind
was in some states
you have to get it written into the
newspaper
in order to have it recognized as a
legal name change and i literally when i
got told is i was like excuse me
like i didn't even know some newspapers
still existed let alone that the law
requires you to write your name in the
newspaper
yeah well you'll be happy to know that
we are actually doing that uh in the
next few weeks
we're when you launch it you know that
people are like wow that is the fastest
product development cycle in the world
what are products that people have
suggested that you're like man we really
want to do that but there's some sort of
obstacle between you know where you are
today and being able to actually do it
i think divorce is the biggest one
interesting so
a majority of americans have negative
net worth and so when they want to do an
uncontested divorce
there's no assets to split it should be
very simple with that said it still cost
three thousand dollars
yeah on average and so where is that
cost coming from
filing for a thousand dollars in filing
fees 2
000 to hire a lawyer to make sure you
fill out the paperwork right
and do not pay can't do that because um
there's lots of human involvement built
into the system
and um there will be one day when people
have their airpods on and do not pay us
whispering into their airpods
but not yet so i'm assuming that you get
blowback if you say hey we want to
automate divorce
yeah people are like oh you shouldn't
let you know do that that shouldn't be
easy there'd be a lot of friction
whatever
how do you just think about you know in
these situations where there's going to
be blowback whether it's right or wrong
just around if you automate something
and make it easier of course more people
are going to do it
is that just uh hey let the free market
decide if they want to do this or not or
like
what's the thought process you use to
kind of think through that yeah so we
have this product sue corporations at
the press of a button and that sounds
very dangerous because
um people could abuse it but what i've
noticed over the past six years working
on do not pay is
the crazies already know how to abuse
the system
um if it really takes them downloading
an app or going on a website signing up
paying for a subscription and going
through this long flow
um they're probably not crazy in the
first place and so we've had very little
i mean i think we've banned about a
dozen users over the past six years so
very little abuse
what were the band users doing um like
1000 cases
we have systems in place that if it gets
too much yeah
it's like trying to sue 1 000
corporations yeah
i only i do you have an example or do
you remember what they were trying to
sue for
i'm not sure i i should talk about okay
for legal reasons but okay so it sounds
like it was pretty ridiculous yeah
uh one of the new products that you have
is an hoa product which i think anyone
who
is anywhere remotely near an hoa hates
it right everyone
uh what does the product do and kind of
how did that come about
i lived in an hoa in san francisco um
three do not pay employees hate their
hoas everyone i've spoken to hates their
hoas and there are all these rights that
people have
regarding this so they can't just um
fine you
uh without any like uh
kind of recourse so do not pay gives you
that recourse stops them from finding
you
um you can complain have reviews see
documents
because it's very secretive sometimes
they hold these secret meetings and
they're like oh yeah we find you one
thousand dollars
uh the building that i live in uh here
in miami literally they have a board
i don't know who's on the board nobody
knows who's on the board and when people
want to move into the building you have
to apply
and like in the application process
they're literally like well it could
take one day or 14.
yeah right and you just like okay this
whole thing's rigged somehow like i
don't know how
right because i don't even know who it
is i don't know what the process is but
they basically get a packet and they
make the decision
and i have this theory that is actually
just one person yeah
who's making all the decisions and it's
like the person who owns the building or
something
yeah has to change yeah so uh how many
what percentage of the products you guys
build are internally
thought of and it's just like a personal
pain point or an employee versus
external like whether it's customers
writing in asking for something or just
like you talk to a friend and they give
you an idea
i say they combine together so the
customers come up with the general
problem like i hate robocallers and then
we use our internal
um hacks to solve that problem so with
robocallers the biggest challenge is
knowing who they are
um you can actually sue robocallers for
up to 1.5 k per call
um but they hide behind these spoof
numbers and they don't give you their
real
name so one of the things i personally
did was
um i realize you can track them down by
giving them a credit card number
and when the decline transaction hits
you find out the business name
phone number and address through the
payment network and then sue them and
then sue them so we've built a honey
trap
credit card for that product for example
so the problem came from our users but
the solution came
from do not pay internally so right now
i go on do not pay i can basically come
up with a credit card i can answer a
robo call i give them the credit card
number
yeah they try to charge the number now
all of a sudden i know who it is and
then you send them the demand letter and
go through the sewing process
and do people get money for this yeah up
to 1.5 k per call
and what these robocallers are really
scared of a class-action lawsuit
and so they were actually settled
quickly they settled on the highest
percentage out of anything even more
than like a security deposit
really yeah how much money do you think
do not pay customers have gotten from
suing the robocallers with this honeypot
credit card so it does take some time so
maybe like 400k so far
that's a lot yeah not compared to our
other products but the people that do it
love it there's this one guy it's his
full-time job he just
answers the phone seriously and he like
bought a like new roof for his house
with all the money he's made from there
and he just answers all the robocallers
give him the fake number yeah and then
he's ready to rock and rolls with it
yeah
wow i literally get the spam risk you
know on the iphone
yeah five six times a day i'm gonna sign
up for the product and i'm literally
going to do it and then i'm going to
have you come back we're going to talk
about whether i got my 1.5 k or not
okay if [ __ ] going after these people
uh i'll give you a free subscription
no no i want to pay i want to pay
because uh i want to document the
process
photo ninja is one of my favorites just
because i was telling you before
i feel like some of the products you
guys have are proactive
and people don't even know that it's a
problem so explain what photo ninja does
and kind of what the problem you guys
solved there was
so we're fighting facial recognition and
stalking
okay what photo ninja does is it will
take any photo of you
um like that one and um make it so
that it's undetectable to facial
recognition and reverse image search
but it won't change the look of the
photo so your friend will still say it
looks the same
but it will look completely different
with this adversarial ai
changing the details and practically why
this is important is
if someone wants to sign up online maybe
for a dating app
um a stalker can go in reverse image
search and find out their true identity
so it protects privacy and it also stops
data from being sold
especially with these apple privacy
changes over the past few weeks
you now can't identify devices as easily
so the data brokers are going to other
techniques like facial recognition
to find out who you are yeah and how did
this product come up
um the same this is something that i've
done myself
and i've thought about and i thought why
doesn't everyone have access to this
and so then you're just like let's just
productize yeah what do you do during
your free time like do you just sit and
think of like how do i push back against
something like
what do you spend your free time doing
just like uh fighting back
these companies i'm the type of person
to wait on hold for like four hours for
twelve dollars
really it's about the principle and
having winning you know
yeah so so this is very much like
there's an element of can i figure it
out
and when you figure it out then you give
it to everyone and you're kind of you
know the virtual middle finger to the
institution
yeah i want to scale myself because not
everyone is as passionate about these
issues or they don't have the time to do
it and so
technology is great for that so like
let's take photo ninja hoa
uh parking ticket like how long does it
take you guys to build one of these
parking ticket uh took about three weeks
to build
but we've gotten the product development
time if we know
exactly what we're gonna do to about
four days really so you can basically
that's how you're able to build 200 plus
products is just you can very quickly
knock these out yeah like one a week
okay and how big is the team working on
this
it's just 13 people just 13 people who
are
not only building but also managing 200
plus features or
products right uh and then how much of
that is customer service
versus actual like product development
we have two full-time customer service
24 7. we're very we we always respond
very quickly and then everyone else is
engineering
and that's it that's literally it it's
very simple we don't have sales
it's all self-service uh what about like
a business person or are you the
business person
um in terms of uh like partnerships i
i don't think it works i think it's
better to just be on the side of the
consumer
so we don't do any biz death and then
managing the actual business itself it's
all you
yeah and we have a accounting firm yeah
yeah
okay uh how much money have you raised
total 16.6 million and we're profitable
now
okay uh and what's like the long-term
thing here do you want to like just
build it forever and never sell do you
want to take it public do you not know
what kind of thought process i think
everyone in america can benefit from do
not pay
from we unfortunately we have homeless
people using our product because they
get parking tickets in their cars we
have
crypto investors using our product and
everyone in between
and so i want to take it public and have
everyone in america and one day the
world using it
yeah i literally think you're gonna do
that so that's pretty cool
uh you mentioned crypto i know that
you've been tweeting a bunch saying that
uh
crypto investors are getting ripped off
i think i saw irs
crypto exchanges like i mean you pretty
much laid it all out
pretty clearly uh what what's the
problem first that you see with a lot of
cause a lot of people watching that
uh are crypto investors so where are
they getting ripped off whether they
know it or not
so three main areas which i'm sure
you're very familiar with this base so
freezing of funds this like if you make
a mistake on the form or they just get
suspicious they'll freeze millions or
hundreds of thousands of dollars
and um we will get that unfrozen for you
how quickly much more quickly than if
you're talking to the customer service
department
okay um the second is i'm hacked um
funds
and so we're building a tracing product
and
what the tracing product will do is it
will force any exchange we'll send it to
every single exchange
if they have an address where it is they
have to freeze it and they have a
responsibility to check
we found a law that says that okay and
then finally um
any sort of ico or misrepresentation
getting your money back
fascinating and so basically that's just
like the equivalent of like a class
action but yeah basically hey i gave you
money this was illegal give me my money
back
yes uh do you fear that the crypto
exchanges and others
uh will be similar like the credit
companies and the cable companies and
they won't like you as well or do you
feel like
this is actually welcomed from them
they're definitely not going to like it
but
my expression in life is the squeaky
world gets the grease the um
majority of people do not send these
things into the legal department and so
when it gets sent to the legal
department
it's a much more expedited process so
basically what you're doing is you are
making it
a better experience for the user and
usually it's the
organization that's doing something that
they shouldn't be doing that's right got
it so it's almost like a
in some crazy way like a check and
balance in the system that's right right
fighting fire with fire
yeah and you just happen to have the
legal letter which most people don't
understand how to do that but you guys
understand
yeah okay uh when you think of crypto
is this it seems very aligned in terms
of the ethos that you guys have right
the decentralized infrastructure kind of
the pushing back against the
institutions and the system
uh you know all the digital kind of
automation like it just feels like you
guys are so
well lined up to really go serve that is
that a
single product line or is that something
that will become a bigger part like how
do you just think about
uh a whole new industry in terms of
what's going on there is that
something that you say hey where i'm
going to go put somebody in charge of
like go win in crypto and build crypto
products or is it just nope we have 200
products and like this is just one of
many others no we really want to double
down
um i as an engineer i see like the
laura's code and like society's
operating system and
crypto is the perfect complement to that
how do you think about the fact that a
lot of the products you have send
legal letters right but in crypto and
decentralized
products or decentralized systems
there's nobody to like receive it right
there's no address to send it to like
how do you get around that
i think um rather than convincing
um a a guy to help you uh
appeal your parking like in the city to
approve the appeal
you can convince the public and the
public is much more reasonable than a
entrenched bureaucrat okay explain that
further so
an ideal world would be legal disputes
are decided by a group of
decentralized people and um if you can
convince them rather than someone with
an interest to deny the appeal
then of course it's more advantageous
got it and so basically if you can
somehow get your case or your dispute
out into the public uh in front of some
decentralized group of people almost
like a jury right to some degree
and do it in an automated quick
efficient low-cost way then that would
be the ideal outcome
uh from a process standpoint and then
basically based on the merit of each
case you'd get this
the kind of end result of the conclusion
yeah and there is a legal framework to
assign
decisions to crypto in the same way that
these big corporations require
arbitration with this arbitrator you can
require that
the the token holders uh decide
everything in your life i enjoy talking
to you because it's
what you're doing from a professional
standpoint the crypto ethos yeah miami
cetera like there's a lot of these
layers that are laid on top of each
other it's actually very similar
right and i think that the way that like
miami politics and and uh
kind of south florida and the um leaning
towards more freedom rather than less
the ability for people to think for
themselves and kind of
uh operate their life and make decisions
for themselves but also be responsible
and accountable for the decisions they
make
uh is very much aligned with the
geography
the industries right and the work that
you do where does that come from like
what like why do you think that that's
the stuff that you're drawn towards
i i think um i'm drawn to it because
it's the better approach
um you're not allowed to say that you're
not allowed to say that
that's your approach um anyone who
disagrees they can go kick rocks
i think that um it's not even about
punishing people or fairness
i think that the approach in some other
areas is anti-innovation
there are products that do not pay does
like um
paying people's dmv fees where we just
pay
so you don't have to send the check do
not pages you pay do not pay and they
we pay and don't charge anything more um
in san francisco you can't do that
because san francisco says
money's throwing flow flowing through
you you have to pay 0.5 percent to us
not even on profit on revenue it's quite
a new gross receipts
tax i don't know but and that's so
literally because you're a company
that is processing a payment even though
you make no money
yes they say you make no money but we as
the city we're gonna make money
we'll make 0.5 just for you to be here
and it's not 0.5 percent of the san
francisco tickets is 0.5
of everywhere even if we were operating
in cape town south africa we'd have to
pay 0.5
to san francisco so if a user in cape
town south africa
wants to basically pay a parking ticket
in
cape town south africa san francisco
believes that they have a right to 0.5
of that transaction that's right and
this was the last move for us
um i was trying to justify being in san
francisco but when we got this big tax
bill from 2020 for gross receipts
i was like okay enough is enough that's
[ __ ] nuts
it really is are you gonna pay it well
uh
we're discussing that i think to be
honest reluctantly
we'll pay it but we'll never give them a
single dollar again yeah
i mean that's like to me i've heard some
pretty egregious things in these cities
do
that may be up there it's one of the
most egregious things yeah and it's not
just do not pay anything related to
fintech has these problems so it holds
back
innovation and so uh stripe
being based in san francisco around san
francisco wherever their headquarters is
do they have to do a similar thing where
they have to pay point five percent to
uh the city of san francisco for every
single transaction that they process
um so there are exemptions for credit
card companies
so if you're truly an incumbent industry
like maybe they've come up with an
exemption but even stripe has moved out
of san francisco to daily city or
somewhere because of this tax
really so they basically they levy
attacks which they think is going to
lead to more revenue but what it's done
instead is it's driven one of the most
valuable private
technology companies in the world out of
their city drove you out of the city
i can't begin to imagine how many other
companies have left the city all because
of this stupid tax
yeah and fair enough on profits but
revenue is ridiculous
and it is only increasing agreed i think
that's i think that's the egregious part
right it's not so much that there is a
tax it's that the taxes on gross
revenue not on any profit and therefore
they want to get paid even if you don't
make money
yeah and the question we ask is what do
we get in return and the only thing we
get in return is restrictions right
last year we couldn't open our business
because of covert restrictions where
miami is completely open
so not only is it not a net positive
it's actually a net benefit
negative agreed uh are you guys gonna go
back into like a central office or are
you remote
i'm a big believer in in-person work
especially for these product
driven companies why there's a magic
that happens when we're all like trying
to figure out how to stop the
robocallers and you can't really
replicate that remote
some functions can be remote but not
everything so it almost feels like you
got like a little pirate ship going here
and you need to all be together to like
really kind of
the small group take on the big
organization yeah and several of my team
members are in miami and
they're thrilled they'll get a raise
from the taxes as well so
yeah they basically get an implicit
right like this
do not pay and now they're gonna go
outside so it's even better
while we're working on that uh we can't
wear sweatshirts outside
we're only in only in the building okay
that's good to know um
let's talk about investing i know that
you started to do a lot of investing um
why are you interested in investing kind
of how did this come up
i am unlucky to have lots of smart
friends from stanford and also the teal
fellowship and
it would be irrational not to invest in
them because
um they asked me for that my help and
they're maybe like four years behind
where i was with do not pay
and so i want to help them and as
friends
and when i see them succeed i've had a
few cases where i've helped a lot and i
didn't invest
and i'm like why didn't i invest so i
want to have a
financial incentive to help them you
don't have to give an example but do you
have an example
of like hey this is the type of uh kind
of access or
like special um you know uh advantage
that you have
is there like one thing that you can be
like oh you know this was a friend
here's how i met them and then here's
kind of what happened
um yeah so i i really like to find
companies before they hit the circuit
if you're finding them after they hit
the circuit then it's just
too competitive or too high a price so
one example is
my friend marcus from stanford he
started a computer chip ai company
called luminous computing
it's a truly amazing company and i
invested in the first round and now it's
um they've raised over 100 million got
it from bill gates and others
and so when you find this person
really you're finding them as a friend
right and you get to know them
and it feels like in that situation like
you almost know them better than
any other investor will because it's
literally your friend that you know
it's not so much you're meeting them for
the first time as they pitch you a
company yeah i like to think of this as
creating my own deal flow sometimes i
convince them to start the company in
the first place
and then i'd like i'll pay your
incorporation just let me invest
tomorrow before it gets too hot
so uh i've done this once or twice
always the best deals yeah
like i don't understand why it isn't
focused on more maybe because it's hard
maybe because like you literally have to
go meet a bunch of people and then they
have not certain companies whatever
but by far some of the best deals are
either you convince them to
raise capital start the business uh take
it more seriously whatever
and i don't know why though i haven't
figured out like what's the
psychological
uh or kind of repeatable pattern there
because it just feels like
each one is so different right there's
such wild cards but maybe that is the
pattern
right is that they don't fit the normal
narrative or they're not looking to
start a business
i i think it's a really great business
model because sometimes even three weeks
later a big fam comes in and
and then they do all the work absolutely
yeah uh
when you're doing this are there
specific focuses that you have or are
you just investing in the person
anything promising based on the person
i've done
uh sas hardware whatever
environment what's the craziest thing
you've done
um it's uh still in stealth okay
can you say what industry or space it is
like is it something that people
just like oh that's weird i know it's ai
consumer okay got it
um when you think about what's happening
in the investing world especially in the
earliest stages i think you and i see
eye to eye
on a lot of things in terms of like
these individual gps or
kind of investors being able to move
faster being able to go earlier
uh being able to build a very different
relationship with the founder and also
being able to provide different type of
help
it feels like that's the future right it
definitely is i think um
it's commonly said that we're seeing
power shift to individuals
and it makes sense when i was a founder
pitching my pre-seed round
there would be these big committees of
people and they take weeks to decide
i have unilateral decision making
authority on a phone call and if
i think it's promising i can invest
there and then and be much more helpful
per dollar invested as well
so my perspective is top five maybe top
ten venture funds they're
protected they're great they've built
great reputations the reason why they
have great reputations because they've
been doing this a very long time at the
highest level
uh and so whether it's benchmark sequoia
you know andrews whoever named your firm
they've been able to kind of repeatably
compound money very aggressively
be helpful to founders and build that
reputation once you get outside of the
top ten
is everyone else screwed like is every
tier two and below
firm just screwed i think it will be uh
commoditized outside of that so okay and
so when you say commoditized like it
literally is just capital and therefore
when the founder picks
it's not necessarily they're picking
between differentiation of the partner
or the firm
that's exactly so sure taking the money
yeah and that's the opportunity for the
individual gps to step in and say hey
i've got some sort of differentiation
that
all the commodities tier 2 and below
don't have and therefore take my money
versus theirs yeah and the
differentiation could be pre-investment
or post-investment like pre-investment
may be an easier process or things like
that
okay and then post investment what do
you see the biggest differentiations
being
um some firms uh the differentiation is
we leave you alone we don't destroy the
company like tiger global i think that
and others do a lot of media they help
with recruiting
and a16z model yeah do you think that
uh these later stage firms that are
deploying literally billions and
billions of dollars and then like hey
we're gonna leave you alone
yeah is that a sustainable strategy is
that attractive as a founder do you want
like you personally do you want
investors more involved less involved
like how do you just think through
uh who you would take money from because
i'm assuming that goes a lot that feeds
into how you think about
yourself as an investor i honestly i'm
such an easy i'm very easygoing so i
don't mind
either approach i think that everyone
will do well at the moment because
um i've seen firsthand just how
backwards
uh the the government and society is
and technology is creating massive new
opportunities and so
although we might be overvalued in the
short term in the long term we're
undervalued
in the short term we're overvalued
potentially yeah but in the long term
we're drastically undervalued
and is that just technology in general
or is that a venture capital investing
like
how do you think about breaking that
down like vc investing because
anything below like 10 billion
is probably worthwhile really yeah why
because the world is so stuck that these
new companies are changing everything
um i come from a suburb in
england and everything is so backwards
there they could really use some of
these companies and it really creates a
lot of value one of the things i keep
thinking about
is uh when my parents were kids everyone
wanted to be a millionaire
yeah now it feels like everyone wants to
be a billionaire right
it used to be that everyone to build a
billion dollar company now it almost
feels like the goalposts have moved
there to
10 billion or 100 billion right like
getting to a billion it's not easy
but it happens way more often than it
used to happen
and so some of that may be just a
macroeconomic you know inflationary type
stuff
uh but some of it also is like people
are just understanding the value of some
of these companies so it feels like the
there's been a shift in terms of uh a
250 million
evaluation doesn't seem as high as it
once felt
right like it's kind of on the path to
go there how do you see the dynamics as
you're building a company as a tech
entrepreneur
like how do you see the the various
dynamics around valuations and amount of
capital you raise all that stuff
changing
i i think it's really to do with the
competition between all the firms
maybe five years ago when i was just
starting to not pay they were all
there were very much fewer venture firms
so the collusion would be higher
i'm not saying there was any but there
was more collusion
but now everyone is so worried even as a
solo gp there are like
dozens and dozens of solo gps so i know
that i have to commit quickly
if i want to invest does that make the
investors better investors or worse
investors like all the pressure and
competition
i think efficiency is always a good
thing got it so even if you're having to
make decisions faster
over the long run that should make you a
better investor yes yeah because it
weeds out the people more quickly
i always remind people that uh warren
buffett has this quote where he's like
you know
even if i'm doing a multi-billion dollar
deal i basically know within the first
five minutes of a phone call whether
we're gonna do it or not yeah and i
think that scares the hell out of people
right because they want the uh safety
and the confidence of we did the work
right we went
we looked at all the numbers like all
this stuff uh and so to me
there's a balance right like yes of
course you got to do diligence you got
to do some work as you get later later
in the stage of a business
but there is this element of just like
if you're investing in people you very
quickly kind of
have a feeling like yes this person is
smart this person is going to be
persistent this person is likely to have
a higher probability of success versus
not
yeah i often know very quickly and i
also know the reverse i know if someone
will invest within five minutes even if
they don't tell me
really yeah why like how do you know is
it just
an intuition feeling i i think it's a
mutual mutual feeling
for sure yeah so it's it's uh just hey
they're not as excited as they should be
i'm not as excited so therefore this
isn't gonna work exactly yeah yeah
do you ever preamp telling them no like
like will you ever
talk to an investor and they'd be like
ah you know what i don't think this is a
fit
i think so because it's very intense
sometimes
yeah intense in what like you have to
open yourself up like intellectual
property wise so
it might not be worth it if you don't
think that yeah so you just hey yeah
this doesn't make sense
all right what's been the biggest
surprise over the last 12 months for you
personally
i thought covert meant that the death of
startups and businesses and tech
companies or it would be very difficult
but the opposite is true tech has
thrived and i didn't see that coming
why do you think uh it's thrived is
there like something that you can point
at or is it just simply everyone went
home and the only way to actually
communicate and do
business and stuff was through
technology i think that
um there are lots of these rules that
the government
and courts and um institutions made
that were anti-technology like lots of
courts said that you have to uh
come into the courtroom but then all of
a sudden they were forced to accept
technology
like zoom court hearings even on the
supreme court
um so that has moved things forward and
across
many industries yeah uh
and i'm assuming you saw a massive
uptick in usage or things like parking
tickets because people aren't driving
anymore
during that time there was a loss in
terms of usage
we saw a huge uptick the biggest was
cancellations
er gyms were refusing to cancel people
which i thought was unjust
gems airlines like all of these folks
and
and
to some degree you feel for them right
you're like hey look we get that you're
under pressure but at the same time
you're basically keeping people you're
stealing from them yeah right
like you're not giving them a service
and you're trying to keep the money uh
we get that you're in pain but that
doesn't mean that you should pass that
pain on to the consumer that's exactly
right business is passing it on
yeah uh it felt a little bit like that
is what people are trying to do with
canceling student debt canceling rent
like all this stuff it's not
so much uh you solve the problem you
just simply
pass it on to somebody else and somebody
that you think can handle it
but most likely can't yeah yeah uh will
you guys do anything
in uh kind of the student loan space or
have you done anything there before
these loan contracts are the most
predatory
they can't even be discharged in
bankruptcy so there are actually very
few laws that protect people from
getting rid of their student debt and
hopefully that changes yeah so it's just
really really hard to kind of get around
yeah uh it feels like that's intentional
yes it is there's a huge regulatory
capture
yeah um are you bullish on the united
states from a regulation and kind of
legal on government
standpoint or are you pretty bearish
compared to the rest of the world
i hate to say this but i'm actually very
bearish i have uh three citizenships
um and i i don't know how long it will
last
uh i think i'm with you yeah like it
just feels like
uh we're headed in the wrong direction
uh on a macro basis for
the country uh it can be reversed right
hopefully it will be
um i think that there's a lot of people
working on important work to do that
uh but it does feel like we've kind of
lost the plot
in many ways yeah and i think lawmakers
just don't understand what they're
regulating there are these zoom hearings
where
the lawmakers don't understand
technology at all so i think we need
like a technical oath of office
as well anyone who's a lawmaker should
be required to like understand their
iphone
can we put you in charge of that i don't
think they'll help me
you're on the not friends list yeah
uh i got three questions for you before
we wrap up uh first ones what's the most
important book you've ever read
um that's a great question um
what's the next question while i think
about that one uh second question is
your sleep schedule so our friends
already sleep they gave me this bed that
uh is thermo-regulated i can put it
really cold
okay you got do you have one okay in san
francisco i swear by it as well i sleep
like eight nine hours how
how did your sleep change once you
started using aids sleep i would say
that way i i didn't realize like just
how cool i need the bed but it's changed
my life it's like the most important
thing you spend more time sleeping than
anything else
completely agree what temperature do you
put on i'm a uh
i'm minus five when i go to sleep it
goes to minus six which i didn't realize
was actually way colder than most people
do it
i think around that right yeah uh
there's somebody who i know who's pretty
well known investor and he said the
first night he got it he was like
i didn't know what he's doing he just
put up minus 10. he will get the next
day he had a cold for like 48 hours yeah
so i was like i didn't do that but i i
do like it very cold
uh third question is aliens are you a
believer or non-believer
um i would say i am
that's a great question i i believe in
aliens yeah i've looked into the fermi
palette paradox a lot
yeah it makes sense why why do you
believe in them
like what like what is the thing that
drives you i'm with you right yeah i
think they're out there i don't think
that we've seen them
you don't think that we're going to see
them like it's more of like they're
probably out there too far away for us
to
actually come in contact but what's the
thing that you point to like this is
like the the biggest data point or the
biggest thing that makes me
half believe i'm a
engineer and a geek and just
probabilistically it's a certainty
i mean the universe is so big
of course there'll be a replicant of
earth somewhere
yeah that's generally the way that i
think about it uh book
you have one yeah i would say trust me
i'm lying
um i don't know if you've read ryan
holiday it's a very good book and it's
taught me about all the deception that
big companies
uh kind of guide to do do you study the
deception so that then you can like
almost like in a judo move use it
against them
i don't know perhaps i wouldn't say it's
the most important i'd have to think
about that but it's certainly a good
book
yeah that's a great answer uh you get to
ask me one question to finish up what do
you have for me
um what does the world look like in 10
years
i think it looks a lot like it does now
unfortunately like
i think we make a lot of progress right
but at the same time
many of the things that are true today
are still true then unfortunately right
and so what i mean by unfortunately is
uh there's the bill gates quote we
overestimate what we can do in one year
undress me what we can do in ten
so i do think that uh we're likely
undervaluing technology
progress you know uh the improvement
make the world safer
wealthier you know all that kind of
healthier all that stuff
at the same time uh i still think that
there will be incumbents
yeah i still think that there will be
startups i still think there will be
innovation and i still think there'll be
plenty of people fighting the innovation
like you know like all the structural
things will remain the same
they may look different there may be
different players but uh
the world if you go all the way back to
literally the ancient roman times
is very similar to how it was today it
just happens that you know now we have
super phones and then we didn't
right um and so i'm one of these people
who tries to separate out like
uh kind of the the micro uh progress and
movement from just like the macro
situation and it feels like uh even if
we were to move to let's say you know
the the most outrageous thing some
people could think of as like bitcoin as
a global reserve currency
yeah okay we would still have incumbent
firms right we would still have startup
like like you still have a lot of the
same structural
things yeah yeah you just have to pay
rent right you may use a different
currency to do it right
i still need food to eat right we're
still going to be trying to you know go
accomplish certain things and so
um i i like to say all the time that
like i'm agnostic
on a macro basis just because like we
have no control over that and we're not
unlikely to change it
uh but on a micro basis i'm very very
bullish because i think that the
technology will improve people will
actually get better lives over time
and so it's you know it's kind of this
weird thing of just don't focus on the
macro stuff and just
focus on the micro stuff and that ends
up being where uh world progress gets
made
yeah i agree with that incremental
changes exactly
uh how can people go find you on the
internet or find more about do not pay
um it's do not pay dot com or i'm jay
browder on twitter
all right uh and are we gonna get more
miami tweets out of you
i think i'm we need a do not pay bot
that is a miami like marketing machine
i think people don't like it so i i
don't wanna upset anyone
i like to be like political you know
just keep oh you like
switzerland yeah all right well people
gotta go follow you on twitter then
yeah all right do notpay.com thanks so
much for doing this thank you